As the music legend (Whitney Houston) said: "The crack is bad." But with all this extra attention
Recently, thanks to Toronto Mayor Rob Ford - what exactly is crack cocaine? Is it really as
'Bad' as she portrayed us to be?
Crack is just another form of cocaine, which comes from coca leaf leaves.
After mixing the cocaine powder with a weak base material, such as baking soda, it changes the composition
A solid is produced, often referred to as 'rock'. This solid material has a much lower melting temperature
The temperature of cocaine melting (90C vs. 190C) is why it is allowed to smoke unlike its smell.
In fact, it's called a 'crack' because of the sound it emits when heated. But why smoke it? Okay,
Lungs are a very fast and effective way to deliver substances into the bloodstream.
For example those who suffer from asthma, use inhalers to quickly put the medication directly into their bodies
. When smoke meets with a large area in your lungs, it also slips through
The membrane, directed directly to the brain, is in less than 8 seconds. This is much faster
And more effective than cocaine which normally takes about 10 minutes
To reach the brain.
However, in both cases, when you reach the brain, the crack and cocaine have the same effectiveness. Initially users
They feel active, alert and more feeling their senses. In the brain, the crack works
On the ventral membranes, the release of large amounts of dopamine - a chemical often associated
With feelings of pleasure and ecstasy. Dopamine travels between brain-called cells
Neurons - are associated with nerve receptors that trigger good feelings. Now, usually, dopamine
The neurons will be absorbed back into the neurons by dopamine transporter, but the crack changes
this process. The crack is linked to the carrier and prevents re-uptake, allowing dopamine
To build and continuously stimulate receptors. As a result, you feel - well - really
Good for about 10 minutes.
But shortly after, dopamine levels in the brain are rapidly decreasing, causing a severe decrease
Often caused depression feelings. That's why many users usually smoke more, hopefully
Reach that ecstasy again. Unfortunately, dopamine levels take a long time
The regeneration is natural, so people contribute to the physical and psychological dependence on crack or addiction, as well as increase
Irritability, insomnia, paranoia or suspicion.
In some cases, crack or cocaine abuse frequently leads to so-called phantom parasites
- The feeling that bugs or insects creep under the skin. This often leads to self-destructive behavior
, Such as scratching or biting, trying to get rid of the imagined bugs.
In the most serious cases, the impact of crack on the heart can cause heart attacks and strokes,
Or even completely stop the heart, leading to death.
Simply put, the ultimate crack possible leads to misfortunes!
We thank Audible.com for giving you a free audio book of your choice at audible.com/asap
Audible is the leading provider of audio books with over 150,000 audible audio bookable downloads across
All types of literature. One of our most recent favorites is the "Sycamore Tree Row" which is
A sequel to "John Gresham" to "Time to Kill". You can download this audio book or another book from
Your choice, free, at audible.com/asap. Then use the free audible app to listen on your device
Apple, Windows or Android device. Special thanks for audible for making videos
Available. Thanks for giving them a free audio book of your choice at asaudible.com/asap
Subscribe to the channel to receive more scientific videos weekly.